因为龙飞是农村长大的嘛，
农村长大的，
其实各种各样的事情啊，
什么爷爷啦，
舅舅啦，
姑父啦，
什么姐夫啦，
就是各种各样的事情，
对小姑娘的事情，
我们也算是添的多，
见的多，
所以我一直都跟养小女孩儿，
你就得像个老鹰一样，
像个老母鸡一样，
得把小女孩儿护在自己的翅膀之下。
我和我老公现在都是二婚，
她前面有一个女儿，
我也是前面有个女儿，
现在都是七八岁，
结婚是两年多，
现在生了一个小女儿，
可正快一岁了。
我老公和他前妻离婚的时候，
他名下是有四套房产，
他们离婚协议约定的是等他大女儿18周岁的时候过户给他大女儿，
他现在名下还有两套房产，
等于说是他的婚前财产，
我们之前和公公一起聊过这个问题，
就是说现在这两个房子要给我们现在的小女儿，
他们也是愿意的，
有一套房子是挂着在卖，
但是我们这个小县城行情不好，
一直也卖不出去，
还有一套是我们现在都在住的，
然后我是说有没有什么协议啊，
就是说约定好可以以后只给我们小女人一个人继承，
就没有什么风险，
但现在过户的话，
因为我们的孩子还小，
万一以后要买卖的话就比较麻烦，
可让他们就答应了。
现在我们聊的是爷爷奶奶。
名下的房产是吧？
不是，
是我老公名下的，
你老公名下的房产就是爷爷奶奶出钱买的房产，
现在你有贷款是吧？
嗯，
没有，
你老公名下有几套房啊，
4套有两个是离婚约定给他，
就是大女儿的，
就是说18周岁给他过户就剩下两套，
这两套都是全款的，
都是爷爷奶奶买的，
都是全款，
现在你们就已经商量好说这个房子以后由你的女儿来继承是不是？
嗯，
现在爷爷奶奶也同意，
你老公也同意了是吧？
都同意的，
就是我觉得他们口头上答应，
我觉得不是很安心嘛，
万一要有以后有什么变化什么的，
没有很好的办法，
因为即便是公证的遗嘱，
也是可以随时改遗嘱的，
那公证遗嘱就比如说有没有什么可以见证啊，
就是必须要通过我改，
没有，
除非是第一直接办过户，
第二直接办赠与公证，
但是这也花钱，
还不如直接办过户呢，
赠与公证花费也很高吗？
也很高，
他也是按照这个房产的百分比来收钱，
你可以去你们当地问一下，
就是办房产的赠予的公证书是按照什么比例收费，
按照房屋的市场价的百分之多少收费，
你看一下你需要花费多少成本和代价，
那就是如果说我们现在住的是不卖的嘛，
那另外一套房子如果卖出去，
我公公也说，
那么。
钱是给放到我手里，
那我就怎么，
我不知道存保存人比较好，
还是说再买一套，
加上我商女儿的名字，
我觉得现在这个时代啊，
别买太多房，
就是手上什先不要买房，
不管你是存大额的定期的存款也好，
还是干嘛也好，
手上多留点现金啊。
还有一个问题就是我现在小孩快一岁了嘛，
那我是没有婆婆，
婆婆已经去世了，
嗯，
我公公说等小孩一岁了，
她来带，
然后我去上班，
但是我身边有一些就是反正不好的待网上一些新闻啊，
我就会在想异性在女宝宝会不会不好，
其实啊，
网上这种新闻呢，
它确实是客观存在的，
但如果说确实你家庭经济很紧张，
只能是公共来带，
那咱们就是防范措施做到位，
家里面到处装监控呗，
我意子能在客厅上也不能装，
到房间装吧，
反正我们家月儿嫂来给我带孩子的话，
我是卧室也装，
客厅也装，
公共房间装的话，
感觉这还不太好，
如果现在条件还可以，
不是那么缺钱的话，
那就把孩子养到会说话了为止，
会清楚的表达了为止，
嗯，
他们彩礼给我，
我是婚前存在一张卡里了嘛，
如果到期了应该怎么办呢？
继续不动他不影响，
那我爸爸妈妈给我的嫁妆的话，
他们是。
就是说也怕这种感情有什么变化什么的，
先别里的啊，
那挺好的呀，
好的，
那接下来再起，
我知道了，
好再见啊，
因为龙飞是农村长大的嘛，
农村长大的其实各种各样的事情啊，
什么爷爷啦，
舅舅啦，
姑父啦，
什么姐夫啦，
就各种各样的事情，
对小姑娘的事情，
我们也算是添的多，
见的多，
所以我一直都对养小女孩你就得像个老鹰一样，
像个老母鸡一样，
得把小女孩儿护在自己的翅膀之下，
刚才有个朋友说，
农村生活这么可怕吗？
就底层老百姓，
善良的人呢就很善良，
善良的人呢又容易挨欺负，
反正我以我的人生经验，
我只能告诉你们一个数据，
这个数据摆在这里，
10个人里面有一个人你是惹不起的，
你只能躲着的，
这一个人包含了哪些数据呢？
比如说精神分裂的，
反社会人格的，
NPE的，
还有那种无良症的，
就像那些自己的孩子都能卖掉的人，
拐卖别人的孩子不会被良心债的人，
甚至还有那种都已经干到了什么妇产科副主任了，
然后栽赃人家孕妇有梅毒，
栽赃人家孕妇有肝炎，
说他们家孩子染上毒了以后得花很多钱就不活了，
你就别要了，
然后把孩子偷偷卖掉的，
这样的人他不会有悔过之心。
他不会有觉得自己良心不安，
甚至他都不会告诉你这孩子他卖到哪里去了。
我想表达是什么意思啊，
不光是农村，
城市也一样，
10个人里面有一个人，
你永远记住，
你惹不起，
反社会人格了，
无良症了，
极端人格了，
偏执人格了，
你惹不起，
记得点赞关注哦。